então eu me convidaram pra falar aqui só
pra vocês
no brasil eu é pensei em falar de um
jeito mas ontem à noite aconteceu uma
coisa aparecer o monstro do pânico
eu estava me divertindo com um
macaquinho da procrastinação
mas aí eu mudei o que queria falar
porque eu estava pensando eu falo pra
gente falar sobre a ciência tecnologia e
as pessoa pensa então vou lá eu vou
reclamar que não tem dinheiro o governo
fez isso o governo fez aquilo e pensei
por que interessa por essas pessoas eu
ficar falando dos problemas que tem além
do mais tem problema em todos os países
do mundo quer dizer o o presidente
tranqüilo nos estados unidos que é o
país mais poderoso do mundo em ciência e
tecnologia quer cortar 20% do orçamento
da pesquisa em saúde quer cortar 15% do
orçamento de pesquisa de engenharia e de
ciências exatas quer dizer ao orçamento
da fundação financia pesquisas em
ciências humanas sociais
os ingleses querem sair da europa e não
vão poder pedir financiamento para a
comunidade européia para fazer pesquisa
todo mundo tem problema então eu resolvi
com a ajuda do monstro do pânico ali não
não falar dos problemas eu resolvi
contar pra vocês algumas coisas boas
algumas coisas ótimas que cientistas e
engenheiros pesquisadores têm feito pelo
brasil pra gente saber das coisas boas
que acontecem aqui porque aqui no brasil
tem um pouco essa expensa mento que a
ciência e tecnologia ajuda a estados
unidos ajuda a inglaterra ajuda alemanha
aqui no brasil se a gente fizer tudo
direitinho d'aquino há um tempo a
ciência e tecnologia vai ajudar o brasil
mas eu quero mostrar pra vocês que já
ajuda e já ajuda muito e eu resolvi
contar pra vocês de cinco coisas que
acontecem no brasil que dependem
totalmente de ciência e tecnologia de
engenheiros bem educados de físicos
químicos médicos biólogos bioquímicos
historiadores antropólogos
a ecologistas e 7 que fazem o brasil ser
um lugar melhor do que seria se não
tivesse essas pessoas se não
acontecessem essas coisas energia
alimentos saúde aviões meio ambiente
tirando aviões que é uma coisa meio
assim que a gente pensou em sair de
gente rica que vai voar de avião tá
certo mas energia saúde e meio ambiente
alimento afeta todo mundo no país é uma
coisa que é essencial para a qualidade
da vida pra vida das pessoas para o
progresso então energia
o brasil é um dos poucos países do mundo
que pode falar que tem o que está perto
de ter aquilo que chama auto suficiência
energética quer dizer um país que produz
toda energia que usa não depende dos
outros não depende comprar de outros
países petróleo carvão o que quer que
seja
e além disso o brasil ainda por cima usa
um tipo de energia que é a bioenergia
que essa que vem da cana de açúcar que é
tão comum pra nós que quando a gente
fala para vocês bioenergia da empresa
onde é que usa a bioenergia de energia
outra vez que vai no posto de gasolina
mesmo que você não põe a álcool não sei
o carro você fala põe gasolina
ali vivem 20% de álcool junto com a
gasolina que é o que faz todos os carros
do brasil dar certo é um troço
espetacular porque o brasil conseguiu
ser a única economia industrializados do
mundo que não depende do petróleo se
aparecesse um daqueles monstros de
ficção científica que acabasse com todas
as moléculas de gasolina do planeta
terra
o único país que continuaria funcionando
no brasil que tem as moléculas de etanol
que estão nos carro único país tem
nenhum outro país do mundo fez uma coisa
desse jeito os americanos com todo o
poder deles de ciências inglês os
franceses alemães eles não conseguem não
conseguiram ter uma alternativa para a
gasolina de petróleo e o brasil
conseguiu porque engenheiros físicos
químicos e economistas do brasil se
dedicaram a fazer uma coisa que em 1985
para ser uma maluquice que era a vamos
plantar cana fazer álcool e por o álcool
os carros fazem andar e hoje faz andar e
faz muito anda certo e além do mais e
emitir menos carbono ajuda o negócio da
mudança climática quando o brasil fez
ninguém está pensando em mudança
climática mas ainda deu sorte que com
esse assunto a mudança climática coisa
ficou muito mais importante
ao mesmo tempo o brasil fez também um
esforço para tirar petróleo do mar
a petrobras a prendeu centenas milhares
de engenheiros educados nas boas
universidades no brasil aprenderam como
é que faz para ir lá no mar furat
primeiro passar mil metros de água do
mar depois fazer um buraco de mais mil
metros e tirar o petróleo que tem lá
dentro e virar aquilo em gasolina é uma
operação de engenharia complexa de fazer
é cerveja os cientistas brasileiros
publicam artigos científicos sobre isso
aqui em certidão de 1988 professor
goldemberg que é hoje presidente da
fapesp escreveu em 1988 sobre o balanço
de energia do álcool etílico pra mover
automóveis cientistas do brasil
continuam estudando isso em 2008 isso
aqui é uma equipe da unicamp sobre a
emissão de gases de efeito estufa na
produção de etanol de cana-de-açúcar no
brasil
os cientistas aqui no brasil aprendem
estudam como fazer a cana em vez de
produzir 80 toneladas por hectare
produzir 148 produzir 200 ou produzir
380 cada vez que se aumenta um degrau de
significa que você usa menos terra aí é
outra terra e plantar feijão arroz café
e laranja o que você quiser mora na
terra faz o quê que desejar fazer um
cientista que tem no estado de são paulo
e no brasil publicam mais artigos
científicos sobre cana de açúcar do que
o cientista de qualquer outro país do
mundo aqui a brasil são paulo estados
unidos índia austrália etc
quer dizer é gente que estuda o assunto
pra aprender sobre aquela coisa pra
fazer coisas com aquilo que aprendeu e
como resultado no brasil em 2014 40 por
cento da energia que se usou a energia
do tipo renovável dessa aqui num
né que que tem limitação que não emite
muito gás carbônico para a atmosfera e
dessa parte que é renovável veja 40 por
cento de energia renovável
nenhum país industrializado do mundo tem
nenhum nem na dinamarca não tenha
finlândia não têm a alemanha não tem a
média dos países da oecd 7% de energia
de fonte renovável está 40% desses 40%
16% do total da energia que usa no
brasil vem da cana de açúcar que é de um
gênio do brasil inventaram um jeito de
fazer um país funcionar com energia da
cana de açúcar
olha aqui no estado de são paulo que
coisa legal isso aqui ó 1980 até 2013
em 1980 62 por cento da energia que se
usava no estado de são paulo vinha de
petróleo em 2013 38% olha como é que
baixou a quantidade de energia vinda de
petróleo e como aumentou a energia que
vem da cana de açúcar
esse é um tipo de mudança que insisto
isso pra vocês todos os países do mundo
especialmente os mais envolvidos estão
tentando fazer não conseguem porque não
consegue achar maneiras de fazer
a alternativa para o petróleo que o
brasil achou outra coisa que o brasil
faz os aviões têm cientistas engenheiros
no brasil que estudam aerodinâmica
estudam fluidodinâmica usam computadores
para fazer as contas etc publicam
artigos científicos com títulos
misteriosos que nenhuma pessoa razoável
deve entender na via stoxx beija diz
tori adaptative mexe finep quer dizer
uma coisa misteriosa complicada mas
porque esses caras se dedicam a fazer
essa esquisitice é entender isso a saber
sobre isso eles são capazes de ajudar a
embraer a projetar esse avião que hoje é
um dos maiores sucesso no mundo de avião
de 100 passageiros todo mundo que viaja
pelo mundo vênus aeroporto do mundo
inteiro esse avião fabricado em são josé
dos campos
essa fotografia aqui do lado esquerdo
estava no projeto de pesquisa que a
fapesp financiou com a embraer para
pesquisadores da une
camp do cta da usp antes de ter o
primeiro avião feito e esse aqui é o
ensaio de computador olha como acontece
direitinho que estava no ensaio acontece
no avião de verdade que é o que quer que
aconteça quando o avião aterrissou na
pista molhada não vai aguardando a
turbinas não coisas não boas podem
acontecer nessa engenharia bem feito
os cientistas engenheiros agrônomos no
brasil
biólogos bioquímicos estudam muitas
coisas sobre agricultura sobre biologia
molecular sobre como fazer alimento
veja que de 2006 a 2010 o rendimento da
agropecuária no brasil aumentou 4,28 por
cento ao ano foi o país onde o
rendimento da agricultura mais aumentou
no mundo aumentou mais do que todos e é
isso que eu falei estados unidos
alemanha frança inglaterra china não sei
o que a china em segundo lugar chile
japão argentina etc soja da mais alta
produtividade maior exportador de carne
de frango até antes de acontecer em
outras coisas que não têm nada a ver com
a ciência tecnologia e é de outro
departamento do do país
e vejam só um dos resultados disso preço
do alimento em cidades no estado de são
paulo de 1974 até 2009
aqui é um aqui e 0,2 quer dizer dividiu
por 5 o preço do alimento porque
aumentar a produtividade da terra
aumentará a produtividade da agricultura
e quem aumentou esse aumentaram não
foram os americanos os alemães é foram
os engenheiros agrônomos bioquímicos do
brasil que fizeram isso acontecer e os
fazendeiros que usaram as idéias e saúde
isso aqui é um caso que eu peguei mantém
centenas mas é um outro desses papers de
nome complicadíssimo que vocês aqui vão
saber ao certo porque a sessão na mas as
maiores faculdades de medicina do brasil
mas é usar biomarkers marcadores
biomoleculares personalizados e biópsia
líquida para fazer a seguinte coisa
o paciente tem
de um certo tipo ele faz é radioterapia
ou quimioterapia
aí o tumor fica tão pequeno que a
máquina lá não vê então dizem que sumiu
tumor
o medo de todo mundo é será que vai
voltar o tumor ou não vai
essas essa pesquisador aqui ana maria
camargo ali no hospital sírio libanês
descobriu um jeito de fazer um exame de
sangue nas pessoas que vai fazer toda a
semana e de acordo com certas coisas que
aparecem ou não aparece no sangue da
pessoa ela consegue dizer um ano antes
do exame de imagem poder dizer ela
consegue dizer se o tumor está
aparecendo de novo na pessoa significa
essa pessoa tem um ano a mais de
capacidade de tratamento para controlar
que ele tomou cerveja significa melhorar
a vida das pessoas aumentará a chance da
pessoa sobreviver a doenças terríveis
tudo cientista do brasil todo gente
educado na unifesp na usp e na unicamp
tá certo que descobre essas coisas agora
faz parte do protocolo do hospital
sírio-libanês fazer isso para todos os
pacientes com aquele tipo de câncer que
tem lá não tiver ciência e tecnologia
que faz que ajuda o brasil a ser melhor
um laboratório muito legal que começou
no ano passado na unicamp em associação
com a universidade de toronto
universidade de oxford e 10 das maiores
farmacêuticas do mundo para estudar um
tipo de molécula chamada que nasi que
serve pra mim é um moleque quando se
identificar o que ela faz direitinho
você consegue descobrir drogas ou
descobrir maneiras de afetar como é que
ela funciona na produção de proteínas
ali
esse laboratório além de ser financiado
por 10 das maiores farmacêuticas do
mundo
a gente conseguiu introduzir uma
farmacêutica brasileiro nesse time a
itália também vai se beneficiar uma
empresa farmacêutica aqui de novo tudo
coisa de cientistas do brasil que é
capaz de dialogar com os melhores
cientistas do mundo em campos como esse
aí ou meio ambiente isso aqui olha só
olha essa resolução da secretaria do
meio ambiente
aqui tá dizendo o secretário de estado
do meio ambiente artigo isso aquilo
e desconsiderando os resultados obtidos
pela equipe de pesquisadores do projeto
biota fapesp
aí ele vai fazer a lei sobre conservação
ambiental quer dizer eles estão fazendo
a lei sobre conservação ambiental com
base nos resultados que cientistas
financiados pela fapesp e pelo cnpq pela
capes pela finep acerto pela fapemig
pela faperj descobrem coisa e ajudam o
governo a fazer lei para conservar
melhor o meio ambiente de novo fiesta e
tecnologia feita por brasileiros no
brasil que ajuda o brasil a ser um lugar
melhor
e olha outro caso aqui muitas vezes e já
deve ter visto isso as pessoas falavam
no brasil faz muita ciência e tecnologia
mas é inútil não serve pra nada não sei
o que eu não sei pra vocês vários casos
que serve olha mais esse aqui os alunos
principalmente alguns professores da
unicamp nos últimos 25 anos criaram 454
empresas 454 que ainda existem tá certo
últimos 25 30 anos gerando no ano
passado mantiveram quase 22 mil empregos
quase 22 mil pessoas tiveram emprego
porque umas mil alunos da unicamp
tiveram a idéia de fazer uma empresa
para fazer uma coisa pra vocês um
aplicativo vocês usam o ifood aí nesse
meio é um dos alunos da unicamp fez esse
troço do ifo é e essas empresas somadas
faturam por ano 3 bilhões de reais o
orçamento da unicamp de um ano é 2
bilhões de reais então se conseguir
fazer uma máquina que gera 54 50% a mais
do que aquilo que custa todo ano para os
brasileiro pagando imposto fazendo coisa
e fazendo todo tipo de coisa aí a wifi
dessa aqui do da mobile
tá certo pósitron faz um negócio os
alarmes dos carros é um monte de grau e
faz impressão digital quer dizer muito
tipo de empresa certo muitas universal
no brasil teriam figuras dessa não sei
por que as outras universidades não
fazem a figurinha
tá certo mas é questão de fazer e
mostrar que tem e quer coisa acontece
então
ver ciência e tecnologia não é que vai
ser importante para o brasil já é super
importante está certo a vida dos
brasileiros é melhor por causa de
ciência e tecnologia criada por
brasileiros no brasil é claro em
comunicação com o mundo usando as coisas
do mundo porque nenhum país é
autossuficiente ciência e tecnologia
mas nós sabemos fazer a nossa parte para
gerar esses benefícios o essencial de
criar essas coisas
é a história de ter profissionais bem
educados em boas universidades e tem um
sistema onde tenha pesquisa nas empresas
nos hospitais no governo e pesquisa e
universidades instituto cada um fazendo
a sua parte para ajudar o brasil a ser
melhor usando ciência e tecnologia
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]